Pokemon I love it I've played the games
I found with my friends and as a kid who
was born in 1991 I was the perfect age
to enjoy Pokemon when it took the world
by storm near the turn of the millennium
however an aspect that's bothered me
more and more as time passed by has been
the direction in which these Pokemon
designs have gone it so before I got
ahead of myself I decided to ask my
followers on Twitter to participate in a
poll the question I asked what
generation of Pokemon had the best
designs with the options being Jen's one
and two Jen's three and four Jen's five
and six or Gen seven and eight these
were the results with almost 80% voting
for the first four generations and if
you look in the comments section
primarily the first three but why is
that why do people have an affinity for
the older designs and not the designs of
the latter half of the series is there a
legitimate truth behind their preference
or is it just nostalgic today I want to
explore the designing principles that
made Pokemon famous in generations 1 & 2
to explain where I think they're going
wrong in the more recent games and to
try my hand at redesigning the latest
generation of starters in the classic
style let's dive in
[Music]
this is the design for the fire starter
Charmander in generation 1 of Pokemon
and this right here is the design for
generation eights fire starter score one
that is quite a difference but how did
this happen well it's sort of a long
story but I'll keep it short in
generation 1 there were 4 pokemon design
artists but only two of those were
character artists the rest were just
programmers who did designs on the side
in generation 2 they hired for
additional dedicated artists two of
which having worked for the company
before drawing the trading cards but
were employed as Monster designers for
generation 2 this brought the character
design team up to eight in generation
three an additional five more dedicated
artists were hired to the company
bringing the total of designers up to 13
generation 4 saw a large exodus of 6
people leaving the company three of
which that were present during
generations 1 and 2 in response to this
gamefreak hired six new dedicated
artists for the team to bring it back up
to 13 for generation 5 an additional 5
more people left the company however
with increasing demands for more
characters to be created 10 new hires
were made creating the largest team to
date for generation 5 at 18 character
designers by generation 6 three more
people had left the team and four more
were hired on bringing the total up to
19 and finally for the production of
generation 7 six more people left the
team and eight new were hired bringing
the total character designers on the
team up to 21 and of those 21 only three
remained from the original eight hires
in generations 1 & 2 but who were the
original artists that worked on the
original generation of Pokemon well to
help me on this pokemon journey is my
good friend Tom a legally registered
Pokemon master in literally every single
game released on here to eat ass and
chew bubblegum and I'm all out
what Ken Sugimori was one of the two
founding members of Game Freak alongside
series creator and Mike [ __ ] boys
Satoshi Tajiri Vikon Game Freak was just
a magazine used to handle the art side
of things so we sort of wound up being
the chief artist for the Pokemon
franchise when it first started and
remain so expect signal we found himself
responsible for designing all the human
trainer characters as well as Pokemon
like by the sword
Venusaur Blastoise Pidgey Spearow fear
Oh [ __ ] me all of these guys and that
also Ganga Ganga was his favorite if you
look closely at his early designs he
really liked to implement tough looking
features to his characters the fur is
distinctly jagged the claws are
pronounced and the texture conveyed with
the watercolours is gorgeous now you may
have noticed we said in some respects he
was the chief artists for Pokemon and
that's because figuring out who did what
in the early Pokemon games is a rather
difficult enterprise but why was that
see at the time the design team was
pretty small with just these three
absolutely lady killers so they all had
multiple jobs to do to meet deadlines
one such a lady killer had koujina
region said we didn't have enough people
it's a job categories were all jumbled
up and we would really do whatever and
that he would make resources within the
game and programmers would make designs
as well except he probably said it all
japanesey a prime example of such
multitasking was by shigeki Morimoto
[ __ ] nailed that first take it was a
game designer and programmer but he also
have designs with the series favorites
such as Florida Florida X again gay
Charizard actually just a cat actually
just a cow actually just a man and new
deal making up the third and final
member of the Pokemon design team was
nope the only thing I really know about
him was that he designed Eevee as well
as Jordan ample area which are some of
my favorites
fun fact I used to be that kid who never
evolved as easy because that one episode
in the show but then one time when I was
playing pokemon silver my Eevee evolved
into an Umbreon all by himself and I
thought that my love for my Eevee had
literally created a new Pokemon and he's
been my favorite ever since
[Music]
with that said for the most part it's
not clear who designed what Pokemon and
that's because largely each design was a
combined effort of two or more artists
no that's not to say one can't identify
who drew what it's actually quite easy
if you know what to look for but more on
that later
at this point the first Pokemon games
were in the middle of being designed and
when looking at his current roster of
design Pokemon Sugimori noticed an area
where they were lacking he said and I
quote Pokemon as its Japanese titled
Pocket Monsters suggests is a game in
which monsters battle each other at the
time I figured that since they were
monsters they should have a tough look
but Midway's true I thought I'd like
some cute ones too there weren't many
designers in the company at the time and
I was doing most of it that is why I
asked one of our female staff like
optical Nishida to join the decision to
design more cute Pokemon was made in
addition to wanting people to battle
with their Pokemon they wanted to
encourage trading also and to do so
needed greater variety in the designs on
offer and so once tasked with creating
some cute monsters as the fourth and
final member of the original art team
for Pokemon Etsuko Nishio went right to
work designing many many Pokemon
including the oddish Bellsprout poliwag
and ponytail lines all the starters for
the first generation and one that would
ultimately become the mascot for the
series Pikachu
[Music]
fascinating
whoo foreshadowing what's interesting is
that when the games are being localized
for Western release to actually change
some of the sprites to make them look
less like the unfortunate result of a
sex crime sprite work was tough back in
the day because the game boy could only
display a whopping total of four pixels
at any given moment the designs colors
and poses had to be kept pretty basic if
you wanted them to be recognizable and
even then they were pushing their luck
sometimes the original 151 were designed
with these kinds of hardware limitations
in mind Sugimori said the game boy
didn't have color that's when we made
the coloring something that could be
easily expressed in black and white it's
precisely for reasons like this that
Charmander was given a spike in his back
and Pikachu was given stripes there to
to help break up the color scheme so
that when the back sprites were shown in
the games they were easier to recognize
with the limitations of the old games
sprite art however the red and green
illustrations for sprites weren't the
only ones given to generation one
no no enter red and blue the various
artists dedicated to sprite an
illustration could diverge and explore
more interesting posing independently
which led to better sprite art overall
and much better illustrations why do I
think these designs were so great they
emphasized that these were creatures
wild animals that you can venture out
into the wilderness to find these
revised designs for red and blue looked
as though they were sketches of wild
creatures from a biologist journal Baron
posing for the camera for the most part
they are either attacking us in a
defensive position or looking off
elsewhere character creatures not toy
adverts Pocket Monsters not Pocket toys
and that's really what made Pokemon cool
is fun for a lot of people including
myself that grew up with the games
generation 2 follows a similar design
philosophy probably because most of them
are either leftovers in generation 1 or
designed almost immediately after I'm
with the same core team present from all
the interviews we came across from the
research of this video this one quote in
particular by Ken Sugimori stood at a
somewhat tally he said I didn't think
the series would continue for so long I
figured there might be a part two and
that would be yes
yeah so he didn't exactly hit the nail
on the head with that one because of the
success that cute Pokemon like Pikachu
had found game freak's design team
decided to Double Down at that angle as
the series went on things like sharp
teeth fur claws and overall edge took a
backseat in favor of more rounder
friendly cute and soft designs and on
top of that despite having the biggest
teams working on the designs to date
generation 6 and 7 produced the least
amount of new Pokemon to the series that
said I would imagine there needed to be
more artists for the later games as they
shifted into the 3d space however once
the anime found success and Pikachu took
the world by storm I personally think
that the design team decided to hedge
their bets on the cute factor more and
more as time went on and so the somewhat
realistic more creature based design
theory was thrown out in favor of softer
rounder more cartoonish design
principles but this is where it gets
interesting in an interview from 2018
Ken Sugimori still the art director for
the series was recounting a survey he
gave to the folks around him before the
release of red and green he said I
printed out the complete pixel drawings
of the Pokemon and asked people which
Pokemon do they like best
the overwhelming winner of the survey
was Pikachu the reason for this survey
was to sort out which Pokemon would
appear in the game given its limited
capacity now the context of this
statement was an interview discussing
the creation of Pikachu and the success
the character found implying that even
before the game was released Pikachu was
capturing the hearts of those that saw
it however in an earlier interview taken
with shigeki Morimoto one of the four
original members of the design team and
creator of Pokemon like Dragon Knight
and mu had this to say we had a poll in
the company once a long time ago to see
which Pokemon was the most popular and
back then the winner was executor now
this statement doesn't conflict with
Sugimori z' necessarily there could have
been many polls taken during that time
for various reasons but what I found
interesting is that it doesn't seem to
follow the cute is always best school of
thought that seems to dominate the
modern designs and what's more is that
survey couldn't have happened recently
either because shigeki Morimoto left the
Pokemon team after generation 3 so after
all this talk how would I fix this how
would I bring the latest diners from the
8th generation into a similar design
philosophy to generation 1 let's start
with who I think is the biggest victim
and example of the new design philosophy
score bunny now believe me I thought
this would be a simple enterprise I
would just take elements from the
original designs and substitute it into
the new scoreboard design so that's what
I did originally I made a list of design
elements from generation 1 I thought
might fit with the design but the more I
did this the more I realized I had to
change the character entirely
I couldn't keep his face as flat as it
appeared I couldn't use the cheap puffs
I couldn't even use the ears and trust
me I tried as many different ideas and
posing as possible and none of it worked
so at that point I decided to take a
step back and start from scratch and
studied some real rabbits which
ultimately led me to this design I
decided that this was the right
direction to go in and built upon that
trying out tons of different designs
asking friends their opinions ultimately
finishing with this my generation ones
core body design I tried to mimic the
sharp jagged first Sugimori would use to
communicate the fire element of his
design I kept the overall white color of
the original while giving him a more
realistic head shape with buck teeth
while of course making it appear like a
journalist sketch of a wild animal not
posing for the camera I implemented the
exact same design philosophy for savile
and grew key to achieve the same effect
when artists were creating the first 151
pokemon they were drawing from childhood
experience and interests taking reality
adding some imagination and voila
Pokemon's personally I think that's
what's largely missing from the modern
designs things feel less handcrafted and
more factory produced you know big les
yeah that's actually basically just a
character that Morimoto made up when he
was a kid he even used to draw flip outs
of them and now his childhood doodles
are recognized and loved all across the
globe isn't that [ __ ] magic
look mark and I are all but certain that
there isn't a discussion happening
behind game freeze closed doors and it's
difficult to fault them for that pokemon
has been one of the most consistently
successful gaming franchises over the
last two decades bus and this is
probably just my nostalgia talking I
kind of feel like the spirit of what
made Pokemon and look like Pokemon has
been replaced by plastic imitations
it almost seems like they've missed the
point of what Pokemon had been
established to be as in the first two
generations
he said pre-ordering a copy of sword and
shield to make myself clear this is by
no means a jab at the animes redesigned
for smoother animation I am a massive
fan and advocate of that practice for
animation specifically I'm speaking Puri
about the design principles behind the
current generation of Pokemon themselves
designs that look like they fit in more
on a store shelf than in the actual
world living and breathing I don't
expect this will change and why should
it game freak's Pokemon is one of the
most lucrative properties in today's
market one that in order to stay
relevant needed to evolve with the times
and that's understandable but a part of
me just wishes that a consequence of
that evolution wasn't ad evolution of
design thanks for watching oh also if
this wasn't enough Pokemon for you you
could check out part 2 of this video on
Tom's channel where he and I break down
the in-game components that make up the
Pokemon series it's well worth the watch
and he makes some terrific content see
you next week guys
you
[Music]